left-hander jose quintana making his
fifth start of the season randy arrozan
he comes in with a 273 average
got it done one out change piece
that's a good spot with that after
establishing it
so the batter now is their third baseman
mike brasso and there's a pitch that is
chased and missed and a fastball thrown
by
their second batter tonight brasso
here's austin meadows lefty lefty match
up here on a full count
and he got him looking and he ends up
striking out the side
so the best
first inning of the season for quintana
against the team that's really
struggling with their bats for the tampa
bay raids it's going to be right-handed
tyler glass now making his sixth start
of the season shohei ohtani will be the
next batter another o2 from glass now
good haul up the middle
of the third baseman
so can i come up with shohei going to
second he will slide in safely
and it was close but he's safe at second
now for mike trout
and now he's trying to steal third he's
gonna be out there
ohtani trying to steal third with one
out and trout at the plate he did not
have a walking lead which is what you
would like to have when you're out at
second base he's kind of stagnant and
that allows mejia to throw a bullet
right down
to brasso and the walk to trout
and
lines it in the right caught there by
margaux
to retire the side here's manuel margot
swinging him is the off speed
differential make a difference so does
it catch suzuki who finishes the out for
out number two and strikeout number four
ready for jose quintana
you know brandon lau
up here with the bases empty in two outs
and he got him with a curveball struck
him out
so the rays at least in the first two
innings have come in as advertised a lot
of swings and misses
justin upton
there's a hundred right by him and it's
one and two and tyler was taking the
walk around the mound he thought he
punched him out
he gets the swing and he was he was
doing the march around the mound to let
the rays throw the ball around the
infield not realizing it was not strike
three and and both uh
tyler and justin upton uh a little smile
there
[Music]
out of the zone
so he goes from
mistakenly thinking he had upped it out
on strikes to issuing a walk now
and now he faces albert pujols
[Applause]
for a moment if he got just a little
piece of that but he did not
he's out on strikes and upton moves up
to second
rojas is a local kid from anaheim
and the breaking ball
cut the mason down to first mejia with
the throw
at the end of two full in anaheim it's
rey's and angel scoreless and mike
brasso with the bases loaded in one out
on the ground deep short that's off the
glove of fletcher in the left one run is
scored here comes another man in
rosarito goes to third hanging on at
first his bossa and the rays get two
fletcher actually deflecting that ball
is going to help willie adams score
that ball actually didn't even get the
glove it got him in the forearm
rosarina's still at third brasso at
first
that's a liner base hit that will get a
run home
rosarina scores on the base hit to left
so diaz makes it a three-nothing ball
game
manuel margot becomes the eighth hitter
to step in
the middle
[Applause]
diaz is gonna go to
third there's the rbi single by margot
scores brasso
and so the rays make it a four run
inning
then we go back to the top of the order
david fletcher
[Applause]
i'm not sure i could tell you nope
wait for the replay he doesn't even know
how he caught it he just did
oh my goodness
wow that is amazing he didn't catch it
fletcher hit it into his gloves two outs
runner at second base here's mike trout
here
swinging at him as he's out on strikes
the slider gets him and what a job by
glass now works around the lead off
double there's really adamas
there's a long one
way back toward left center field and
that ball is gone
a 3-1 pitch
the third home run of the year for a
dallas and the rays pick up
their fifth run
i mean that ball right down the middle
and he caught that one flush
no doubter
jared walsh who's playing right field
stepping in
and there's a swinging miss
[Applause]
to complete that strikeout justin upton
and he gets a swing and mousse on the
fastball down and a hundred and that
will do it for the angels here in the
fourth base runner in the ball game for
the angels jorge ohtani will bet
centerfield
so the batter now is anthony rendon with
one out
[Applause]
and he doesn't miss it it is up in the
zone but not high enough angels and they
caught it out there with the hat
slaggered i think he made the play on
that way he's channeling his no way
ramirez with the hat catch in the
bullpen on the home run ball
have the right side shift on meadow's
the batter
how about fletch
how about short right field
out i'm looking how far that throw is to
be the collector that is an unbelievable
play by fletch guys remember he is
playing shortstop tonight
but the quick hands of david fletcher i
don't think anybody has quicker hands on
this team than david fletcher gets it
and puts it right on the money to albert
28 year old ryan thompson makes his way
to the mound so he will face rendon
tied him up and this one's got a piece
of random this one is hurting
no doubt this is off his knee yeah
bottom part of his leg he is in pain
that is right off the kneecap
the fans are reacting here
so wendell the runner at first and
the hitters manuel margot
that's a high fly ball deep to left down
the line and that's a fair ball and gone
and well margot has unloaded a two-run
blast here in the ninth
and that will give the rays a little
breathing room
it's now a 7-3 game
a hanging change-up
[Applause]
right out over the plate elevated margot
not fooled at all
just trying to close this one out
ground ball that might do it
at first the double play ball to damas
lao to brasso and the rays take the
first game of this four-game series
they defeat
the angels it's a 7-3 final